das hier sind die besten Wings die du
dir zu Hause zubereiten kannst und das
beste du brauchst dafür nicht mal eine
frituse los geht's dafür brauchen wir
natürlich chicken ich habe hier einmal
Flats und Drums und die werden wir jetzt
vorbereiten und zwar habe ich dafür ein
Päckchen Backpulver auf dass ich
ungefähr die gleiche Menge Salz gebe
jetzt müssen wir das Hähnchen richtig
gut abtrocknen denn natürlich das
Hauptziel eine knusprige Haut zu
bekommen und dann können wir unser
Hähnchen auch schon in eine Schüssel
geben und mit unserer Mischung bestäuben
wenn wir es da drin haben einfach einmal
durchwerfen wieder aufs Lech geben und
so geen wir es jetzt in den Kühlschrank
etwa zwei Stunden später sehen unsere
Wings so aus und wir geben Sie jetzt in
den Ofen 230° Umluft für 20 Minuten
kümmern wir uns jetzt um die Soße ich
gebe ein bisschen Butter in den Topf
zwei Knoblauch Zehen was ich Euch jetzt
zeige ist für hot saauce ihr könnt
natürlich auch einfach barbecuoße dazu
geben Ketchup ihr könnt die Wings pur
essen so oder so wird's lecker Knoblauch
zur Butter die Butter ist geschmolzen
jetzt geben wir eine hotsauce dazu seid
ihr bereit für die Wings guckt euch das
einfach mal an und jetzt schwenken wir
die durch und geben ein wenig von
unserer hotsauce dazu sodass sie von
allen Seiten gleichmäßig bedeckt sind